thank you dear cecilia bonfertal and
dear friends of digital europe ladies
and gentlemen
since our virtual meeting
approximately a year ago at masters of
digital
i have embarked on a journey across our
digital europe
i met for example companies in
luxembourg that are building
an ultra secure satellite communication
system
thanks to quantum technology
i listen to students in ireland who are
using artificial intelligence
to improve animal health in farms
and i spoke to startupers in slovakia
who are bringing new technologies to the
market
from nanosensors
to rna sequencings for example
so each of them had an incredible story
to tell
stories of entrepreneurship
stories of innovation
innovation at the frontiers of human
knowledge
stories that you all know very well
because these are your stories
too and all of these encounters have
given me so much confidence
about europe's digital future
and one year ago
i gave you a promise
i promised we would strive to make the
2020s
europe's digital decade
in two ways with unprecedented
investment
and with a modern set of rules for
europe's digital sector
now
one year on
we are delivering with both
funds and legislation
if you look at our recovery plan next
generation eu
it is investing in projects like those
i've just mentioned
next generation eu
has over
125 billion euros
in digital investment
so massive resources
that have already started to revitalize
and reshape our economy
i think this is our marshall plan for
digital europe
and besides investment we have started
to write a new rulebook for europe's
digital decade
first there is the digital markets act
and the digital services act
in those two acts we lay out the basic
principles
for all digital companies in europe
we kind of create a level playing field
for all businesses
and clear rights for all users
secondly
there is the artificial intelligence act
with this act we have created a guard
rail
for one of the most crucial technologies
of our age
of course we want companies and
programmers to keep advancing and
innovating and we're expanding our
investment in ai
but as we do this
we must protect people and their rights
with clear rules on the high risk
applications of ai
and let me mention in this regard
the winner of last year's future unicorn
award
by digital europe
is a hungarian company called encompass
they have developed a software
to support oncologists
in choosing the right therapy for
patients
and see thanks to artificial
intelligence
the software can forecast each patient's
response to thousands of targeted
therapies against cancer
so this is simply amazing
this could be the next scientific
revolution
and i really believe ai must be a force
for good
for greater human welfare
and the ai act can truly channel the
power of artificial intelligence
in the right direction
in the coming weeks and months we will
add more chapters to the new rulebook
for our digital economy
for example later this month
we will present our data act
it will give businesses and individuals
more control over the data they produce
while using a connected device
and more control over how their data are
processed
and later this year we will come with
our cyber resilience act
which will establish common security
standards for all connected devices in
europe
so the digital transition needs clear
rules
people need to know
that they can trust the technology in
their hands
business need predictability to plan
their investment
and this is exactly why we have come up
with the most ambitious agenda
for digital reforms and investment
in our union's history
ladies and gentlemen
next week
we will present a crucial piece of this
agenda
and this is europe's first ever chips
act
and i would like to use this opportunity
to give you an insight
on our forthcoming proposal
semiconductors have become front page
news in these months
when the global chip shortage has slowed
down the global recovery
our factories closed in east asia
and entire production lines here in
europe came to a standstill
so we all realized what europe still
lacks
when it comes to one of the most crucial
assets for the digital transition
because we all know there is no digital
without chips
but allow me for a moment to reverse our
point of view
instead of focusing on what we do not
have
let me focus on europe's strength in the
field of semiconductors
europe is the world center
for semiconductor research
if today's advanced chips pack tens of
billions of transistors in each square
centimeter of silicon
that's thanks to european technology
and some of the essential machines
to produce the most advanced ships in
the world
are made in only one place in the world
right here
in europe
and we are strong in specific sectors
such as chips for cars or for industry
4.0
so they are crucial niche
where europe is a global leader
but i want us to become a strong player
all across the chip's value chain
and where others see deficiencies
i see potential
and this makes me confident that the
goal we have set for the european ships
act
is ambitious
but it is achievable
by 2030
20 of the world's microchips production
should be here in europe
that's twice as much as today
in a market that is set to double in the
next decade so it means quadrupling
today's european production
the european ships act will back this
ambition with considerable investment
it will enable more than 12 billion
euros in additional public and private
investment by 2030
and this will come on top of more than
30 billion euros of public investments
already foreseen
now backed by next generation eu horizon
europe
as well as national budgets
so these funds will be more than matched
by private investments
and to put numbers in perspective
european companies in the semiconductors
field are now investing roughly 6
billion euros per year
so the european ships act can be a game
changer
and our work will focus in particular on
five areas
first there is research
we will invest in a field where we are
already punching above our weight
focusing for instance on transistors
below three nanometers
and on disruptive technologies for
artificial intelligence
when it comes to research and innovation
europe can basically go from strength to
strength
second
from the lab to the fab
we must translate our excellent research
into industrial innovation
we will invest in ships design and in
pilot lines for prototypes
thus bridging the gap between the
laboratory
and the actual manufacturing of the most
innovative chips
my third point
is on production capacity
europe needs new advanced production
facilities
for instance europe relies entirely on
foreign producers
for leading edge ships
and these facilities come with huge
upfront costs therefore
public support can be necessary to
attract private investment
and for this reason
we are adapting our state aid rules
under a set of strict conditions but
this will now allow for the very first
time
public support
for european first-of-a-kind production
facilities which of course benefit all
of
europe so my fourth point is that this
is not just about mega fabs
and therefore the european ships act
will also support smaller innovative
companies
it will help them in accessing advanced
skills
or for example have industrial partners
and access to equity finance and finally
finally
my fifth point is on supply chains
it should be clear that no country
and even no continent
can be entirely self-sufficient
so europe will always work to keep
global markets open and connected
it's in the world's interest and it's in
our own interest
but we need to tackle the bottlenecks
that slow down our growth
a situation where entire industrial
sectors
rely on only one or two producers in
east asia is simply not sustainable
and certainly not in today's world
so to change this
we will work on semiconductor
partnerships with like-minded partners
from the united states to japan for
example
and with that we can create more
balanced interdependencies
we can avoid single points of failure
and we can build supply chains
that we can truly trust
ladies and gentlemen dear friends
last fall i visited asml in antophan
one of our european champions for
semiconductors
machines designed and built here are
crucial to produce ships in all corners
of the world indeed from singapore to
the united states
and it's not our only champion
infineon
nxp
st microelectronics just to name a few
europe is also becoming more attractive
for foreign giants like intel
and europe keeps leading the world on
innovation
think of our research centers
for instance imac in belgium
they are spearheading
the efforts to create a new generation
of energy efficient
and climate-friendly chips
and this is why i believe we can achieve
the goals we have set with the european
ships act and europe's digital decade
we are putting out the investment
and the strategy
but the key to our success
lies in europe's innovators
world-class researchers
in the people
who have made our continent prosper
through the decades
europe is the continent where all the
industrial revolutions have started
and europe can be the home of the next
industrial revolution too
so let's join forces
to make it happen
and ladies and gentlemen dear friends
last
but not least
through the master of digital awards
you honor people and companies
who help drive europe's digital
transformation
and thus
i am truly honored
to be among the winners of this year's
award and let me show it
the wonderful award here it is
thank you very much for that i am really
honored
i take it as a recognition of the
commission's engagement to deliver the
digital decade
and of course congratulations
to the other winners of the master of
digital awards
and thank you very much for your
attention